MALE SPEAKER: Good
afternoon, and welcome
to Talks at Google in
Cambridge, Massachusetts.
Today it's my great pleasure
to introduce Beth Shapiro.
Dr. Shapiro is here today
to discuss her book,
"How to Clone a Mammoth: The
Science of De-Extinction."
We have the science today
to restore extinct species
to life, but should we?
The ethical challenges
are enormous.
Using DNA collected from
remains as a genetic blueprint,
scientists aim to engineer
extinct traits, traits
that evolved by
natural selection
over thousands of years,
into living organisms.
But rather than
viewing de-extinction
as a way to restore
one particular species,
she argues that the
overarching goal
should be the revitalization
and stabilization
of contemporary ecosystems.
Dr. Shapiro is an
evolutionary biologist
who integrates
molecular phylogenetics
with advanced
computational biostatistics
to reconstruct the influences
on population dynamics
in a wide variety of organisms.
She is Associate
Professor of Ecology
and Evolutionary Biology
at UC Santa Cruz.
Her work has appeared in
numerous publications,
including "Nature and Science,"
and she was a 2009 MacArthur
Foundation Fellow.
Please join me in
welcoming Beth Shapiro.
[APPLAUSE]
BETH SHAPIRO: Thank you.
Well, thank you very much
for inviting me to come here,
and for taking the time out
of your busy and hectic days
to come and listen
to me, especially
after David Duchovny,
who I'm sure was
quite entertaining, and
probably more entertaining
than I can possibly be.
So let's just leave
it at that, right?
I thought I'd begin with a
video that kind of explains what
I do when I'm in the field.
So the quality of the
sound is a little bit poor,
but the video is kind
of neat, so bear with me
here for just a sec.
[BEGIN VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-So this is really cool.
What we just found,
you can see, is
one, two, three, four
pieces of mammoth bone here.
This is part of a vertebrae,
so you can see how big this is.
And the neat thing
about this is that these
are the small pieces, which
means that the stuff that's
washed downstream.
See, these pieces are actually
still frozen in the permafrost.
We can't get them
out of the wall,
which means they're going
to be really well-preserved.
Just heard that big splash of
water back there that means
another hole's broken through.
Here comes the water.
We better get out of here.
[END PLAYBACK]
So admittedly that last part
is a little bit ridiculous.
But in my defense, the
water is really gross.
What that is is, that's active
placer mining, gold mining
sites up near Dawson City
in Canada's Yukon Territory.
So during the spring
when the snow melts,
the miners collect all the water
in these big holding ponds,
and then they pump it up
to wherever they're trying
to wash away that permafrost.
And they wash away
whatever's thawed and then
let it stop for a bit, let the
next little few inches thaw,
and then wash that away.
Their goal is to get rid
of all of that permafrost
to get to the gold-bearing
gravels beneath.
But while they're doing,
that we find hundreds,
thousands, sometimes tens
of thousands of these bones
that are incredibly
well preserved.
And we bring them
back to the lab
and use them for our research.
So I'm a biologist, an
evolutionary biologist,
or a geneticist, or a
molecular paleontologist.
Lots of ways to
describe that, including
some new ones that were used
in the introduction just
a moment ago.
So what does a biologist want to
do with frozen bones collected
from the permafrost?
Well, my research
is actually focused
on trying to understand how
populations and communities
and ecosystems respond to rapid,
large scale changes in climate
in the present day.
So when we see and hear about
climate change going on today,
often what we hear about
are large scale changes
in precipitation patterns
that change the distribution
of water, maybe
difference in the storms,
and of course species that are
on the verge of extinction.
And when we hear about
this stuff reported
by the popular
press, often we're
just told that everything is
going to hell in a hand basket.
But if you're a
biologist, and you
want to avoid some of these
particularly dire predictions
here, you might
want to understand,
or be able to predict in some
useful way, how the species
and communities that
we're trying to protect we
are going to respond for the
change in the climate that's
predicted for the next
decade to century.
So if you keep up with the
climate change literature
at all, you'll no
doubt be familiar
with this particular graph here,
or something similar to this.
This is Michael Mann's
Hockey Stick graph,
and it's called a
Hockey Stick graph
because it kind of looks
like a hockey stick
laying on the side.
Here's the end of the stick
and the part that goes up here.
This is the average
temperature around 1960,
and this is really
just a plot of how
that temperature has changed
over the last 1,000 years.
So you see the temperature
remained pretty constant,
maybe declining a little bit
through time, until a couple
hundred years ago, when
it shot up pretty quickly.
Now this plot can be
extended into the future,
and we see all
sorts of predictions
of climate increasing,
the temperature increasing
exponentially throughout the
next 50 years to 100 years.
Of course, this is not the first
time in Earth's recent history
that the planet has experienced
a really rapid increase
in temperature.
If we extend this plot backward
to the last 50,000 years,
we see an interval right here,
in between around 18,000 years
ago and maybe 12,000
or 13,000 years ago,
when the average global
temperature increased
by about eight degrees.
This here is only about
1 and 1/2 degrees.
This is an
eight-degree increase.
Some of the work that
we're doing right now
is suggesting that
this last period
of really rapid increase-- this
is the transition from the peak
of the last Ice Age into
the Holocene warm interval
that we're experiencing
today-- this last period
possibly happened over
less than 100 years,
or even as quickly
as a few decades.
So this is a very rapid period
of widespread global warming
that's going to be associated
with all sorts of changes
in temperature
and precipitation,
and changes to the
biological species that
are living out there.
So what I try to do with my
research is ask the question,
how did species and communities
and populations and ecosystems
change in response to this past
period of rapid climate change?
And is there
anything that we can
use from learning about
what happened in the past
to make better decisions about
how to spend the limited time
and energy and resources we
have to conserve species today?
So the field I work in
is called ancient DNA.
It's pretty clear what
ancient DNA means.
It means old DNA, not old
people DNA, but actually
really old DNA, like
mammoths preserved in ice.
I work at a place
called Beringia.
Beringia spans
this part of Alaska
here, across the Bering land
bridge into eastern Siberia.
All of this white stuff here
is just an indication that it's
not as deep in the ocean there.
So during the Ice Ages, when
much of the water on the planet
was taken up into making
giant glaciers sitting
on top of the continents,
this was actually exposed.
This was exposed land.
And this, of course, is
a very important corridor
for movement of many species,
camels and horses going
in this direction, bison and
people going in this direction,
to move between
the two continents.
So today Beringia
looks like this.
I'm actually in that
helicopter, taking this picture.
And I'll show you a picture
of that fantastic flying
machine in just a moment.
Looks like this.
But in the past, and
during the last Ice Age,
it looked more like this, with
a very rich and diverse plant
community that was grazed on
by a rich and diverse herbivore
community that
was hunted by lots
of different types
of carnivores.
There were mammoths and
mastodons at various times,
and North American camels,
several different species
of big cat.
There were giant bears,
arctodus, that if it stood up,
was 16 feet tall.
And there was even
a giant beaver
that was the same
size as me, which
is the funniest extinct animal.
So we fly out here in this
fantastic flying machine.
You'll notice that there
are some windows missing,
which is great, in
case anybody wants
to smoke on board in
celebration of taking off.
I'm not saying that happened,
but I'm not saying it didn't.
And we stay in
five-star accommodation,
as you can see here.
This is a picture
that I took of my tent
by backing up and
unfocusing my camera lens
so that I could really get a
picture of the depth of field
of mosquitoes that we
were dealing with up there
in the Arctic.
And we walk along
all sorts of places,
wherever the
permafrost is thawing,
like these placer mining sites.
This is, again,
back in Dawson City.
The previous pictures were
from the Taimyr Peninsula
in North Central Siberia.
This is, again, an
active mining site,
where you see them washing
down the permafrost.
And here are my folks kind
of wandering around, waiting
to pick up bones that are coming
out as the dirt washes away.
So in a day out in
the field, we'll
generally collect anywhere
between five and 20 bags
of bones like this.
Most of the bones
there are bison.
There are also mammoth
and caribou and horses.
And sometimes we get lucky and
get wolves or bears or lions.
And we take a piece out of these
bones, a tiny piece-- that's
just a regular Dremel tool
with a little cutting disk--
and bring that piece
back to the lab,
grind it up, and extract DNA.
And then we correlate the
amount of genetic diversity
that we observe in any
species at one point in time
with the size of the population.
So in essence, we can use
DNA extracted from thousands
of these bones to learn
how populations were
growing or shrinking or
moving across the landscape,
or whether there were
local extinctions followed
by replacements of populations
coming in from somewhere else.
And we've learned an
awful lot of stuff
over the last couple
decades of doing this.
For example, we've learned that
bison, horses, and mammoths all
peaked in population size
around 40,000 years ago,
and then started to climb.
And this is
interesting, because two
of the main hypotheses about
what caused the megafauna mass
extinction at the end
of the Pleistocene,
when we did lose
mammoths and many other
of these big species,
were that they didn't
like the peak of
the last Ice Age--
it was too cold and
too terrible for them--
or that people turned up
and hunted them to death.
But if the initial decline
begins about 30,000 years ago,
that's 10,000 years before
the peak of the last Ice Age,
and 15,000 years before any
evidence of large numbers
of humans in North America.
So it looks like we're off
the hook for the beginning
of these extinctions, although
I'm not quite willing to let us
off the hook for the
ultimate extinction
event of many of these species.
We've watched carnivore
populations grow and move
in response to changes in the
dynamics of the herbivores
that they preyed on.
And we're starting to learn
why some species, like caribou,
survived.
They liked to live
where humans didn't,
which is a pretty good trick.
And other species, like
cave lions, went extinct.
And I and colleagues who
work on this stuff often
get to publish these papers in
pretty high profile journals.
They get lots of press
attention, and people care.
People are really interested.
They call.
I'm often really excited to
talk about what we've learned,
and how it applies to
present day problems
in biodiversity conservation.
But they only ever really
ask me one question.
And it's kind of annoying.
And since there really is
no sound bite-size response
to this, I decided to
write this book, right?
So the field, the
field of bringing
extinct species or extinct
traits back to life,
has come to be known
as de-extinction.
Now, we are all partly
familiar with de-extinction
because we were there when
it happened the first time.
And we know what happened.
We know it all went
off without a hitch.
Everything was
perfectly good, right?
We remember this?
But today we're not going
to talk about dinosaurs,
because we can't
clone dinosaurs.
There are no dinosaur
bones that contain DNA.
They're all rocks.
There's no DNA in rocks.
Regardless of what you
read in high profile,
nice publications like
"Science" and "Nature,"
there's no DNA in dinosaurs.
You heard it here.
So how are we going to
bring back a mammoth?
We know there's DNA
in mammoths, right?
The first step, the first
thing that everybody
thinks we're going to do, the
first process that's proposed,
is, let's clone it.
Let's clone a mammoth.
Well, cloning is actually a
specific scientific process,
a specific type of work that's
actually known as somatic cell
nuclear transfer.
So in our cells,
we basically have
two different kinds of
cells, germ line cells,
which are sperm and
eggs, and somatic cells,
which are everything else.
What normally happens,
a sperm and egg
come together, fertilize,
create a small thing, a zygote,
that differentiates.
And that particular
cell that they create
has the power to become any type
of cell in a whole body, hair
cells, skin cells, heart cells,
liver cells, every type of cell
there is.
Somatic cells already
know what their job is,
and they can't do anything else.
So the idea of somatic
cell nuclear transfer
is to trick a somatic cell into
forgetting all the instructions
necessary to be
that type of cell,
and to revert into a state
where it can actually,
then, become every
type of cell in a body
and create a whole being.
So the most famous,
and the first,
example of somatic
cell nuclear transfer
was an experiment in
the mid-1990s that
brought us Dolly the Sheep.
Probably everybody's
heard of this.
This was work by the Roswell
Institute in Scotland.
And they took a somatic
cell-- in this case
it was a mammary cell from
an adult sheep, a ewe--
and they took those cells
and basically starved them.
They starved them of
nutrients in a dish in a lab.
At the same time,
they took an egg cell
from a different breed
of sheep, and they
removed the nucleus, all
the genetic material,
from that unfertilized egg.
So you had an egg
with nothing in it
and starved cells right here.
Put them next to
each other, zap them
with electricity, the membrane
bursts, the nucleus here
dumps into the cell.
Zap it again, and the
proteins in that egg
somehow cause the
genetic material
from that somatic cell
that's a bit stressed out
to forget all the instructions
and turn into the type of cell
that can become everything
in a particular animal.
This is then implanted in the
surrogate host, who is yet
another species of
sheep or breed of sheep,
and eventually Dolly was born.
And Dolly was a genetic clone
of the mammary cell donor,
and not of either the egg cell
donor or the surrogate mom.
Easy.
So how do we do
it with a mammoth?
Well, we go out in
the field and we
find one of these fantastically
preserved mammoths.
And we remove some cells,
and then we stress them out,
and then we stick those cells
in the nucleus of an egg.
And it does that
little magic thing,
and then we stick it
inside an elephant,
and it grows up to be a baby.
Release it, and it's all good.
Right.
Here we have our first problem.
So we do find a lot of
incredibly well-preserved
remains up in the Arctic.
This is an example.
This is a horse jaw
that we found up
in the permafrost
near Dawson City that
dates to sometime in the
last 100,000 years or so.
This is one of the very many
well-preserved mummies that's
been found in Siberia.
And a couple summers
ago, there was a report
of this incredibly
well-preserved mummy that
was associated with what looked
like a viscous red material
that they thought
might be blood.
But regardless of
how well-preserved
these things are,
there is not going
to be a living cell to be found
in any remains of any mammoth.
Once an organism dies, the
cells and the DNA within them,
begins to get broken down into
smaller and smaller pieces
almost immediately.
First it's enzymes within our
own body that chop up the DNA.
If you're a mummy, you might
have the guts burst, and then
all of that microbiome
that lives in there
is going to circulate
throughout the system.
And those are living microbes
that will just catabolize,
eat up that DNA.
Sun is particularly bad.
UV light will hit those mummies,
just like it hits us when we're
alive and we walk outside.
But unlike us, the mummies are
dead, or the bones are dead.
So there's no
proofreading mechanism
to fix the damage caused
by solar radiation.
Water, hydrolysis,
oxygen, all these things
are terrible for DNA survival.
And in fact, the DNA begins
to break down immediately
and is eventually broken
down to a state where there's
nothing that's recoverable.
Where there are no living cells,
there's no living genomes,
there's no intact DNA, we
cannot clone a mammoth.
Thank you for coming.
Just kidding.
Obviously I'm just kidding.
So what's the next step?
So we all probably
heard last week,
because there was a
lot of press attention,
that an international
group of scientists--
but mostly a group that was in
Stockholm, led by Love Dalen --
had published the
genome sequence,
complete genome sequences,
of two mammoths,
one mammoth from Wrangel Island
that was around 3,500 years
old, and another mammoth from
Siberia that was somewhere
in the realm of
40,000 years old.
So now what we have this
is nice and big list of As,
Cs, Gs, and Ts, the
nucleotides that
make up DNA, that will
spell out the instructions
to make the genes that make
the proteins to make a mammoth,
to make it how it looks
and how it behaves.
So surely, the
best thing that we
can do to bring a
mammoth back to life
would just be to synthesize
these long stretches of DNA,
and then get them
into the chromosome,
and then put the chromosome
into this egg cell,
and then do the thing with
the going around and making
the mammoth.
Yeah.
That.
So the problem with this is
that a complete genome-- well,
there's lots of problems
here, but let's just
start with this-- they said
it was a complete genome,
but in fact, it's not
really a complete genome.
In fact, we don't actually know
the complete genome sequence
of any vertebrate
animal, including humans.
And I know that that sounds
a little bit strange,
since we've been saying
for quite a long time
that we know the
human genome sequence.
And to be fair, we do know most
of the human genome sequence.
We know, at least,
all the parts that
contain genes, the
important parts that
make the proteins that make
us look and act the way
that we do.
But there are parts
of the human genome,
and of every other mammalian
genome and vertebrate genome,
that are extremely hard
to sequence through,
these complex patterns of
highly condensed repeat things,
often near the center
of the chromosomes
and near the end
of the chromosomes.
But there isn't any existing
sequencing technology
that can get through.
And this means that we don't
know the whole sequence.
We don't know how
long these are.
We don't know if
they're important.
We don't know whether there
are any genes in them.
We don't really understand
quite yet what they do.
But the truth is, we don't
have the complete sequence.
For mammoths, it's
even harder than that.
And there are two
reasons why it's
harder for anything that's
extinct-- in particular,
we're talking about
mammoths here--
than it would be to assemble
a complete human genome.
The first is that
the sequences that we
recover from these bones
are very short and damaged.
And this is because
of all of the stuff
that I just talked about--
solar radiation, enzymes
from in the body
and from microbes
that are in the soil that will
get into the particular bones
after they're buried and eat
up the DNA-- all of this stuff
is acting to break those
DNA sequences down.
So if you imagine that I
could get modern DNA out
of something that looks like
a nice big party streamer,
ancient DNA looks
more like confetti,
but not confetti that's
in that good of a shape.
More like confetti
that you might
find on the ground
in the gutter the day
after the parade, when it
rained the night before.
And maybe there were
elephants in the parade,
and flocks of passenger
pigeons flying overhead.
Not good It's not good.
The other problem
is that the samples
are full of all kinds of stuff
in addition to mammoth DNA.
So if you imagine that I
took a piece of my own hair,
or a cheek swab, and extracted
all the DNA in there,
and then sequenced
everything I got
when I extracted DNA, nearly
everything that I could get out
of there would be my own DNA.
That's because I'm
living, and my DNA's
in pretty good condition,
and there's not
that much that might be
contaminating my DNA sample.
In 2006, I was involved
with a group that
used the new sequencing
technology, next generation
sequencing, to
shotgun sequence--
that's what we call sequencing
everything we get out of a DNA
extract-- a mammoth
bone for the first time.
And this is what we got.
About half of the
sequences that we
recovered from that sequence
mapped to mammoth DNA.
The rest of it was stuff
like soil bacteria,
environmental microbes,
other stuff that was probably
also soil microbes that we
just hadn't sequenced yet,
so they weren't in the database
for us to compare the data to,
some contamination-- we often
find human, dog, domestic cat
and bird sequences
in our extracts.
That's not that surprising.
So about half of what
we got was mammoth.
We were pretty
bummed about this.
We thought, well, half.
That's terrible.
How are we ever going to
be able to piece together
a complete genome with only
half of what we're getting
is actually ancient DNA?
It turns out, a decade later,
we know that this was actually
an exceptionally
well-preserved sample,
and that most of the remains
that we recover have less than
20%-- less than 10% percent
of the DNA that we want is
actually the DNA from the host.
If you've heard of the
Neanderthal genome that
was published recently, the
first Neanderthal genome
sequence, they used a
couple of different bones.
And none of those
bones had more than 1%
Neanderthal DNA in them.
That's pretty
standard, especially
when you're not coming
from a kind of cold region.
So what we have is this kind
of junked-up bit of confetti,
if you can imagine confetti that
looks more gross than this. a
And what we really want
re just the purple bits.
So how do we go about
finding the stuff
that we want from amid
the entire mess of stuff
that we actually get?
How do we well what
DNA is mammoth,
when most of what we're
getting is actually just
soil microbes that we
really want to throw away?
What we do is we map
the data that we have,
these broken little tiny
pieces of fragments,
to the already-published
complete genome
sequences of living
animals, or complete-ish.
They're in good shape.
They're much better
than anything
that we would be
able to generate
from an ancient sample.
So, for the mammoth, we would
map it to an Asian elephant.
And for the Neanderthal, we
were able to map it to a human.
We take these broken
fragments, and we match them
where they go, using this
genome sequence as a guide
to figure out where they go.
One of the key problems
that arises immediately,
when you think about this, is,
what if something weird has
happened in the evolutionary
time between when
a mammoth lived and when
the Asian elephant lived,
since that common ancestor?
If something weird happened,
like a big duplication--
there's a whole new bit of
DNA, or something changed
a lot-- that would be missing.
We wouldn't have that part
of the genome on our map.
We would think that whatever it
was of mammoth DNA that matched
that real part of
the mammoth genome--
because it's not part
of the elephant genome
that we're using as a
scaffold-- was probably
just environmental DNA,
and we would throw it out.
So it's harder to generate a
complete sequence for something
that isn't alive,
where we can't generate
the genome sequence by itself.
And one would think
that if you're
trying to identify the
parts of the genome that
are most important
to make a mammoth,
look more and act
more like a mammoth
instead of like
an elephant, those
might be some of the
important places to look.
The other problem is that
having the DNA sequence
is not the same thing
as having a living cell.
We're getting better at
being able to synthesize
these long strands of DNA
that we might use to generate
a complete sequence,
but we don't
know how to wrap those things
up properly and get them
into a chromosome in a
state where they're actually
going to make genes
and make proteins.
And we don't know how
to get chromosomes
into a cell in any logical way.
So it looks like, if
this is the pathway,
Plan B is what
we're going to use
to bring a mammoth back to life,
we're stuck at that first step.
And that's not going
to work either.
Of course, there's another way.
So the last plan-- and
this is the one that really
is at the core of
what people are
thinking about
for de-extinction,
is to engineer a mammoth.
And this is really similar to
just thinking about cutting
and pasting your DNA.
So you find a part of the genome
that you want to swap out--
say, some gene that's
different between elephants
and mammoths-- you cut it
out and paste in the version
that you want.
So mammoths and Asian
elephants diverged
from each other something
like six million years ago.
We now have genome sequences
from both of these sequences.
And we can start combing
through those genome sequences
to look for places where
the two species are
different from each other.
Sequence a whole bunch
of Asian elephants,
find the place where they're
all the same as each other,
a whole bunch of mammoths, and
see where they're all the same.
And if these two are
different, then that's
probably kind of critical
to making a mammoth look
and act like a mammoth.
So imagine, then, you
had a little machine
that you could use, a
machine that you could
send into the genome
of an elephant cell
and identify exactly that
place that you want to change.
And also you could give
that little machine
a package to take with it, which
was an artificially synthesized
bit of mammoth DNA that
it would take with us
to this place in the genome.
And that's machine could
then cut out the elephant
version of the gene, and
swap the mammoth version
gene in there in its place.
Well, we have that machine.
That machine is
called CRISPR/CAS 9.
And this is something
that you might
have heard a lot
about in the news
in the last couple of weeks.
There was a Chinese
team recently
that used this
particular enzyme.
This is a naturally
occurring enzyme,
not a machine that
we've built. It's
something that
bacteria and archaea
use to protect themselves
from invading diseases.
People have figured
out how to use
this to harness this machine
to identify parts of a genome
and cut it out.
And this Chinese team had
done that with human embryos,
raising all sorts of ethical
issues about this incredibly
powerful new technology.
So this machine here,
this molecule here,
is your little machine.
This is an enzyme.
And here's the part
of it that recognizes
the specific part of the
elephant genome sequence.
We send in there a bit of
synthesized mammoth DNA.
The machine here
chops it in half.
It's like a molecular
scissors, that's its job.
Of course, DNA in a cell
doesn't like to be in half.
So it has a couple of
different mechanisms
that it uses to fix those
double-stranded breaks.
We harness the cell's
own repair mechanism,
and stick in there that
synthetic piece of mammoth DNA.
So we end up with
an elephant that's
just a little bit mammoth-like.
So what do we change?
I said there are about six
million years of evolution
separating these two species.
And indeed, there have
been some efforts, so far,
within last couple
of weeks even,
to catalog the differences that
existed between these two guys.
One of the first
differences that was found
was a work was done by Kevin
Campbell's lab in Manitoba
in 2010.
They found that there were
only three differences, three
changes that needed to be made,
to change the Asian elephant
red blood cell, hemoglobin, a
component of the red blood cell
which is responsible
for carrying oxygen
around the body, into the
woolly mammoth version
of the red blood cell.
And they made these changes
in cells in the lab,
and they were able to, then,
do a little tissue culture
experiment, a gene
expression experiment,
to try to figure out what
those differences did
for that version of
the hemoglobin protein.
And they found that, when
these changes were made,
the hemoglobin was much
better at carrying oxygen
around the body at
low temperatures.
This is clearly something
that is an adaptation that
arose in mammoths as the
tropically-adapted ancestor
of these two species
moved out of the tropics
and into the Arctic.
So this might be a
powerful new first approach
to going about trying to create
or change an elephant genome so
that you could create a mammoth.
So what else should we change?
Well, there's a team
that's nearby here
that's led by George
Church that have been
working on this for some time.
And using this CRISPR
type of genome editing,
they've so far been able to
swap out 14 different genes.
Every one of them that
they've tried so far
has worked with this
CRISPR technology.
These genes are associated with
increasing thermal regulation,
maybe thicker subcutaneous
fat layers and thicker hair,
or the red blood cells.
Also things that are
associated with diet,
the metabolism, all sorts of
things that one might think
were important to making an
elephant look and act more
like a mammoth.
And so far, they have
succeeded in creating something
that is about a small
fraction mammoth in a dish,
in a lab, which, of course, is
a very long way from creating
a living, breathing mammoth.
But it is helpful,
and it does say
that, with this genome
sequence, which we do have,
for the most part, and with
this CRISPR/CAS engineering
technology, which we also have,
we can then create an elephant
cell that's alive that
contains a few mutations that
make it look and act
more like a mammoth.
And at that point,
we can go ahead
and use cloning, the
traditional technology used
to bring something back.
Of course, the next step here,
creating a surrogate mom,
growing it up, putting it in the
environment-- I like to call it
Phase 2 of de-extinction--
is probably
even harder than what we've
been able to accomplish so far.
And when you read
about de-extinction
or hear about it on the
radio, often there's
a focus on this first part,
Phase 1, with the thought
that just because
we can get this far
means that we are super
close to being able to bring
a mammoth back to life.
But that is really,
really not the case.
We are far from being
able to create a mammoth.
So the next thing we would
have to do in this step
would be to find
a surrogate mom.
So for many species,
this might be easy.
If they have very close
evolutionary relatives that
are still alive, then
it might be relatively
straightforward to finding
a surrogate mom that could
carry an edited embryo to term.
But the more evolutionary
distance accumulates
between the living species
and the extinct species
you're trying to bring back,
the harder this is likely to be.
There may even, in some cases,
be some unpleasant constraints
associated with
trying to do this.
I know I say here that you
probably don't want a photo,
but you're a bunch of
computer scientists,
so you probably do want a photo.
So here is one.
You were hoping for
something grosser, right?
I knew that.
I'll try to find something
grosser for next time.
This is a Steller's sea cow.
And the Steller's sea
cow, this is a foot.
This is the scale
bar right there.
This is a big animal.
Steller's sea cow went extinct
a couple hundred years ago.
We hunted them to death.
One of these guys could
feed a crew of 30 or so men
for a couple of weeks.
So you can see why,
potentially, they
were nice prey for people
who were out on the ocean.
They lived along the
coast of California,
up across the Aleutian Islands,
and onto the Commander Islands.
And they went extinct
really recently,
a couple hundred years ago.
The closest living relative
to the Steller's sea cow
is a dugong, here.
And if one were to estimate the
size of a newborn Steller's sea
cow by looking at the
of newborn manatee
and dugong to the
size of their mom,
a newborn Steller's
sea cow would
be larger than its mom, which
just wouldn't be pretty.
So in some cases, there may
be some physical constraints,
technical problems, technical
challenges associated
with this part of Phase 2.
it's also pretty clear
by now, and becoming
more and more
clear through time,
that we as organisms--
and every organism--
are more than the
sum of just our
As, Cs, Gs, and Ts that
make up our DNA sequence.
In fact, we are a product
of both our genome sequences
and the environment
in which we live.
And that environment
begins in the world.
The same would necessarily
be true for an elephant,
or an edited elephant that was
attempting to be a mammoth.
Asian elephant and
mammoths genomes
are already, without thinking
about anything, about 99%
the same, the same as
we are with chimpanzees.
And so if you put
something that's tiny,
tiny bit changed
inside a mom who
has pretty much the same genome
and pretty much the same genes,
and the developmental
process here
is going to be
controlled and affected
by her hormonal environment and
her diet and what's going on,
how do we know that the
changes that we've made
are going to have any
effect whatsoever on what
this animal looks like?
And once it's born, it's
going to be born into
and live in an elephant society.
Elephants eat the
dung of their moms
just after they're born
in order to establish
the microbial community
that they need to break down
the food that they eat.
This newborn mammoth
elephant hybrid
would eat the dung
of an elephant
so that it could establish an
elephant microbial community.
We know how important
the gut microbes
are in determining how we look
and how we act and how we feel.
Why would the same not be
true for an animal like this?
It would then join
an elephant society
and eat whatever
food elephants are
fed in captive environments.
And all of these
things are going
to affect the way that
this animal behaves
and the way that it looks.
This is something
that's unquestionable,
and yet something that we
haven't really questioned.
And speaking of captive
environments, this, in my mind,
is probably the biggest
challenge associated
with mammoth de-extinction.
We know that elephants
don't fare particularly well
in captivity.
They often fail to
reproduce in captivity.
If they do, they
injure and sometimes
even kill their offspring.
Until we have figured
out how we can
meet the physical and emotional,
psychological needs of mammoths
in captivity, I think
that we should not
be using mammoths for
this type of research,
or keeping them in captivity.
Maybe for other species, these
particular types of concerns
are less.
Birds we may not need to
have-- some bird species
might not have very
much parental guidance,
so maybe it's ethically
simpler to bring birds back.
But there are, of course,
technical challenges
of bringing birds back
that we don't have when
we're dealing with mammals.
So there are many different
ethical considerations
to be aware of.
But again, this is
something that I
think not enough attention
has been paid to.
And finally, it would be
remiss of me not to point out
or to acknowledge that the world
has changed a lot in the time
since many of these
species have gone extinct.
And bringing something
back, and introducing it
into an environment
where it doesn't live,
is definitely going to
affect those environments.
Environments are
not stable things.
A species doesn't go extinct,
leaving this giant, gaping hole
into which we could
just stick it back.
They'll change.
They'll adapt.
New species move in.
Everything changes.
This here, this is the range
of the passenger pigeon, which
is one of the
species that's been
proposed to bring back to life.
Where would a passenger
pigeon, a bird that
flocked in the billions
and fed on forests,
killing huge swaths
of forest all at once,
where would it go if we
were to bring it back?
Clearly, the ecological
implications of de-extinction
need to be considered
carefully for any species
that we're considering
bringing back
before we go down the road
to actually making it happen.
So de-extinction, can we do it?
Not yet.
We can't yet.
But the technology is increasing
rapidly, both in Phase 1
and in Phase 2.
And there will come
a time where we
can do this for some species.
So maybe we should start
focusing more on the question,
should we?
And as somebody who's
written a book about this,
it's clear that I should have
a very informed and direct
opinion about this.
And I do.
I don't know.
I honestly don't know.
There are a lot of
different species
that have been proposed as
candidates for de-extinction.
This is the heath
hen that used to live
in Martha's Vineyard, mammoth,
passenger pigeon, thylacine,
Steller's sea cow, the gastric
brooding frog, the bucardo,
a type of ibex that used
to live in the Pyrenees.
All of these things
have been posed
by groups who were interested in
working them to be resurrected.
But I think that the
most important thing
to do in deciding whether
we should proceed with any
of these species, or any
other species that someone
might want to bring back, is to
really try to understand why.
Why might we want to
bring a species back
that's been extinct
for a long time?
Why is this such a
compelling area of research?
Why are so many people so
fascinated by this idea?
And to answer this question,
just in the last few minutes
here, I'm going to
return to mammoths.
And I'm going to ignore the
fact, for a moment, that it's
not possible to do and that,
ethically, it's probably
a terrible idea to
deal with elephants
and to bring mammoths
back to life,
and talk about why we
might want them back.
Because I do think there are
a couple of compelling reasons
to think about bringing mammoths
back, or at least creating
an elephant that looks and acts
a little bit like a mammoth.
The first is ecological.
So there's a place up
in Northeastern Siberia
called Pleistocene Park.
It's been established
in about the mid-1990s
by scientists with the
Russian Academy of Science
named Sergey Zimov.
He started buying up
land near his home
at the Northeast Science
Nation and preparing
a park for the resurrection
of Ice Age animals.
So far he has bison
imported from Canada,
some species of horse, five
different species of deer.
And he's been doing
some experiments, where
he's keeping them out of some
parts of Pleistocene Park
and letting them graze on
other parts of Pleistocene Park
to see what the effect
of having those animals
there is on the ecosystem, the
environment itself as a whole.
So here's a picture
that Sergey took.
This is very early spring.
This is the side that doesn't
have any grazing animals,
and this is the side that
does have grazing animals.
And what you see here is
a really stark contrast
between the type of
vegetation that's there.
Here we have pretty much
only one species of grass.
It's very low productivity.
Really can't support grazing
herbivores in any way.
And over here-- remember,
this is early spring,
so the grass hasn't had time
to regenerate-- you still see
lots of green.
And you can't really
tell, but there
are a bunch of different
species of grass that are there.
What he's found is that these
animals, by their presence
alone, moving around, turning
over the soil, recycling
nutrients, distributing
seeds, have essentially
created their own habitat.
They've made the habitat that's
necessary for them to survive.
In fact, they've made
so much that even
after the very
cold Arctic winter,
there's still some green grass
there left for that community
to come back the next year.
And he's observed not only
that these animals are
happy and healthy and
living in these areas,
but that other species have come
to visit the park because it's
such a rich source of food,
things like saiga antelope,
an endangered species.
Essentially, these animals,
with their presence,
have recreated that
rich tundra grassland
that used to be there,
potentially making habitat
and saving species that
are in danger of extinction
today because this
is all they've got.
The next reason
is more emotional.
I think few of us are willing to
accept the idea of a world that
doesn't have elephants.
But elephants are an
endangered species.
Asian elephants are in trouble.
Their habitat is declining.
We're having a difficult
time stopping poaching.
Human populations are growing.
And every year fewer and
fewer Asian elephants exist.
What if we could
use this technology
not to bring mammoths
back to life,
but to create elephants
that are capable of living
in a more diverse environment,
elephants that could live
in temperate zones
or Arctic zones,
moving into the types of
habitats that once occupied
by mammoths?
We could use this technology
not to bring something that's
gone and has been
gone for a long time
back, but really to save a
species that's still alive
today, but in danger
of extinction.
Let's not use this
crazy technology
to de-extinct mammoth.
Let's use it to save elephants.
And that's what I think
the most compelling use
of the technology that's being
developed here really is.
Not to bring stuff
back that's gone,
but to change and manipulate
and give a genetic booster shot,
if you will, to populations and
species and communities that
are in danger of going
extinct because of our actions
today, because of
climate change,
because of decreases in
habitat that evolution itself,
alone, can't keep up with.
This, in my mind, is
the most powerful use
of de-extinction technology.
Thank you for your attention.
[APPLAUSE]
I'm happy to take any
questions, if anyone has any.
AUDIENCE: So my
first question comes
back to what you said at the
very beginning, which is this
is not what your field was.
Has the question caused
you to become interested
in this question and change
what you're working on?
Or has it just caused
you to write this book
that you're now on tour about?
BETH SHAPIRO: Yeah.
No, I'm definitely
more interested now.
And actually, writing this
book was an experience
in becoming more
and more interested.
We now have a couple
of different projects
where we are hoping to use
ancient DNA technology to learn
what the diversity was
in populations that
were extinct in the
past-- not extinct,
but where recent
changes in population
size-- like black-footed
ferrets in the central plains,
for example, are nearly
genetically depauparate.
They're all almost the same.
And that's because of a
recent, really tight population
bottleneck and near extinction.
These guys are now in trouble.
There is a disease
that's killing them off.
It's not something
that we can do yet,
but it would be possible to look
at black-footed ferrets that
are preserved in
museum collections,
or living cells that they
have in the collection
at the frozen zoo in San Diego,
and learn how much diversity
there was in the past, and
then use this technology
to inject that diversity
into living populations
of black-footed ferrets.
I'm also really
interested in birds.
There are tons of
species of birds that
are in danger of going extinct.
And yet the biggest
technical hurdle here
is that we can't clone birds.
There's no way to
actually get that egg
cell at the point where
it's ready to be fertilized
but it hasn't yet
been fertilized
because of the peculiarities
of the bird reproductive tract.
And so there is no
way to clone birds.
There's a different
type of technology
that one would use to change
the genome sequence in birds.
And we've been working
with other groups
to try to refine that technology
for endangered bird species.
It's kind of neat.
When a bird, chicken egg
is laid, for example,
the germ cells, or the
primordial germ cells
that are going to go on
to become sperm and eggs,
aren't actually in the
gonads yet because the gonads
don't exist yet.
But they're migrating around
the outside of that embryo
to the place where
the gonads will be.
At that point, you can stick
a needle in the egg cell
and suck out some of those germ
cells, primordial germ cells,
without harming the
embryo or the egg.
And you can put
those into a dish,
and you can actually edit
those primordial germ cells.
And then you can stick
them back in to another egg
as it's just been laid, and
they will migrate around
the embryo to become those
primordial germ cells.
So the egg, when it hatches,
will be totally normal.
But its offspring will have
the edits that you've made.
This is a really cool,
and potentially powerful,
technology that's really
at the early stages
of being developed.
AUDIENCE: So you
posed the question as,
can we and should we?
Do you not feel like
we live in a world
where it is inevitable
that, probably
within the lifetime of
people in this room,
people will actually
decide to do this,
and there will be baby elephants
with a little bit of woolly
mammoth, or baby humans with
a little bit of Neanderthal,
or whatever your
favorite choice is,
as one of these inevitable--
BETH SHAPIRO: Those are two
particularly hard choices,
right?
There are a lot of technical
hurdles with both these.
And with Neanderthals there's
a big ethical question there.
Neanderthals are
people too, right?
So how are you going
to get informed consent
to bring one of those
guys back to life?
It's a slippery, touchy thing.
I don't think we
should go there.
Whether we do or
not, I don't know.
Scary.
But there are a
lot of scary things
that can be done
with CRISPRs, so I
don't think we should
talk about those either.
Mammoths, some of
the biggest hangups
are actually in the
cloning process itself.
Every time an
elephant gives birth,
the hymen actually grows back.
And the hymen has a
tiny little hole in it
that's just big enough for
the sperm to get through.
It sits there during the
pregnancy to actually maintain
the pregnancy.
It's a big, heavy thing, and
it's a two-year pregnancy.
So gotta hold it in
there for two years.
There certainly is no way to
insert a developing embryo
into the uterus of an elephant
without destroying that hymen.
I think that to
this stuff is going
to involve m growing elephant
eggs on the backs of mice--
I know that there are groups
that are actually working
on doing that-- and maybe
completely artificial wounds
where the entire
gestation process takes
place outside of a species.
And all that stuff might
be developed, probably not
for de-extinction,
probably because we
want to use it for humans.
There certainly
isn't any money being
invested into
developing technologies
for the purposes of extinction.
But yeah, I do I think that
somebody's going to try?
Yeah.
More likely, somebody is going
to achieve what George Church's
lab achieved, and then
the press is going to say,
George Church cloned a
mammoth, which is not
what George Church said at all.
And to be fair, there
was only one media
outlet that said
that, and I won't
say what it is, since I know
this is going on YouTube.
AUDIENCE: OK, so to play
devil's advocate here.
So let's say that we succeed
in genetically engineering
elephants so that they can
survive in different habitats
than they naturally live in now.
That feels to me like
going up to the elephant
and saying, well, we've
destroyed your natural habitat
here.
But we found this other
place in North Dakota
where you can live.
And so we're going to
genetically reengineer
your offspring and
have them go to that.
BETH SHAPIRO: I'm
not saying that this
should be a substitute to try
and protect the species that
are alive and in danger today.
But I think that we have
come to a point where we're
playing conservation triage.
And we might need to reach
deeper into our arsenals
and find the most
powerful weapons we
have to stop these species
from going extinct.
I would rather have
elephants in Africa,
but I would rather have
elephants in North Dakota
than no elephants.
AUDIENCE: On the
one hand, I don't
like to anthropomorphize
the argument,
but on the other hand, if we did
anything like that with humans,
it would be ethically abhorrent
on a number of fronts.
AUDIENCE: If we tried to save
humans from going extinct,
it would be ethically abhorrent?
AUDIENCE: Or if we relocated
them and said, well,
we're genetically engineering
you, so that's going to be OK,
without consent
from participants.
AUDIENCE: You're
making an argument
that says we should
focus on saving elephants
where they are.
And I totally agree
with you on that.
I completely agree
that we should do that.
But I'm saying that
it's not enough,
and it's probably not
going to be enough.
There are situations
we can't control.
Look at the rhino, right?
We haven't been able
to save the rhino.
The habitat where it
lives is something
that we can't deal
with because of
current political situations.
What if we relocate
elephants to North Dakota,
and then in that time,
when they're gone,
completely fix the political
climate and the expansion
of human populations in Africa?
And then we can put
them back in Africa.
Would having them live in
North Dakota for a short period
of time be a terrible thing
to do if our ultimate goal was
to create a native
habitat for them
to thrive as a living species
rather than something that's
just gone?
AUDIENCE: How do
we actually know
modifying which bits
is going to help
elephants live in North Dakota?
BETH SHAPIRO: We have no idea.
And this is really
part of the process.
So we now have these
genome sequences,
which is like somebody
handing you two massive phone
books for New York
City and San Francisco,
but without any names
and addresses in them.
The next step is trying to
figure out where the genes are,
what the genes do, doing
these experiments like George
Church and his lab
are doing, where
they switch a little bit out,
and then they test those cells.
You can actually perform
some assay in tissue culture,
in culture, to figure out
whether those changes have done
something, and what
those changes might
be before using them to
go on and make an animal.
But yeah, we're very much at
the early stages and trial
and error.
We don't have to make animals,
though, that are somehow unfit.
We can do those early
stages in the lab.
AUDIENCE: I guess I was
thinking, like, even later.
Like if we know how to modify
the blood cells to live
in a colder climate, how
do we know how much of that
we need to do, or whether
that's going to be helpful,
and whether the
elephants are even going
to survive in North Dakota?
BETH SHAPIRO: Yeah.
We don't know, do we?
But yeah, we'll know
more after we've tried
than we knew before we tried.
All right.
Thank you very much
for your attention.
[APPLAUSE]